قال جدعون ساعر الوزير في المجلس الوزاري
الامني المصغر من حزب معسكر الدوله بزعامه
بيني جانس قال ان اسرائيل لا تزال بعيده
عن تقويد حركه حماس وان سحب القوات من غزه
في ظل استمرار الحرب كان قرارا خاطئا
واضاف في تصريح نقلته اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه اذا كان هناك من يعتقد بان
سلطه بديله لحماس ستقوم في قطاع غزه بينما
هي واقفه على رجليها حسب تعبيره فان ذلك
لن يحدث معتبرا ان الفلسطينيين هناك
يعيشون حاله رعب مميته من سلطه حماس
وارهاب تجاه مواطنيها وفق تعبيره لذلك فان
اسرائيل ملزمه بتحقيق هدفها على حد قوله
وقال ساعر ان هناك اهميه كبيره لاستمرار
حكومه الطوارئ واسرائيل لا تزال في حاله
حرب داعيا الى مقاومه الضغوط الخارجيه
التي قد تشتد من جهته قال وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار بن كفير ان قرار
سحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من مراكز حماس في
قطاع غزه خطا فادح وخطير وسيكلف ارواحا
بشريه وفي تعليقه على الصواريخ الذي اطلقت
على نيتي فوت من منطقه غادرتها قوات الجيش
قال بن كفير ان ذلك يثبت ان احتلال القطاع
ضروري لتحقيق الاهداف القتاليه
n